[Music]
all right november clouds outside we had
all that sunshine yesterday we told you
today though clouds would return to the
regional from that pacific storm that
was slamming into the west coast 72
degrees outside right now humidity at 27
percent not too bad your 24 hour change
six degrees cooler than yesterday
remember we were closer to 80 yesterday
and we do see those breezy winds and
those winds will continue at least for
the early part of the evening currently
outside here your number 72 for sky
canyon same goes for centennial hills
spring valley you're at 70 even 74 for
north las vegas very pleasant very comfy
outside at this hour 72 for henderson 71
for mountains edge southern highlands
you're currently at 69 degrees regional
temperatures 67 for indian springs 74
for you up there in northeast clark in
mesquite 81 for laughlin and death
valley checking in right now 83 degrees
in inyo county there's a look at our
satellite and radar composite this is
both combined notice all that shower
activity seems to be up north very
spotty dry here clouds over us right now
but as we zoom in and show you what
happened 12 hours ago actually you can
see that we did have plenty of rainfall
way off into the bay area as that
atmospheric river moved down it started
to diminish and weaken more and all we
got were the clouds here so those clouds
are more bark than bite winds however
have been gusty for the day today we
have seen them up to 30 we'll show those
to you in a bit but how does it look for
this evening well those winds will
decrease tonight look at this 8 30 those
winds not as bad as what we saw earlier
today and then wednesday winds should
stay fairly tame but still remain gusty
down for the lake and down the colorado
river valley for thursday and friday too
new graphic to show you ready for this
one guys this is las vegas so we put
this together i call this one the eight
card stud
eight get it eight cardstock
oh i'll do that next time
yeah i'm gonna put that on the request
all right all right it carts down 7 p.m
we're looking at partly cloudy skies
still keeping those clouds around for
the evening so these clouds around this
evening and then tomorrow they'll clear
out temperatures there you go 67 64 and
60 degrees for later on this evening
really proud of that graphic
thank you
thank you thank you 75 degrees for
tomorrow sunny and nice we'll keep
temperatures nice and pleasant so we're
back to sunshine tomorrow i say nice
because that is actually a very nice
temperature for this time of the year we
should be around the low 70s 74 for
north las vegas along with spring valley
77 for green valley 76 nellis and 73 for
septon hills for tomorrow
outside of town 72 for prim 73 boulder
city and 83 for laughing now there's a
lot going on in this eight news now
eight day graphic okay because we've
been talking about this we got all the
home games on here
the unlv home games we got the knights
home games we have the raiders home game
because why because we support and love
las vegas and our home teams right
so all those are going on this week it's
going to be a great week temperatures
closer to 80 for the weekend and then
cooler next week that's your most active
forecast guys
looking good ted thank you